this election has been a wake-up call
for Democrats everywhere and and people
feel that this is a cry for real change
in the Democratic Party I'm guessing you
have strong feelings about what needs to
happen right now
absolutely look we have got to
understand that in these very serious
times we have got to rethink our roles
our roles as citizens and that means
that we have got to participate in the
political process in a way that we have
never done before the truth is we can
stop Trump's bigotry and we can stop his
denial of climate change and many other
things if millions of people come
together and say sorry mr. Trump this
planet belongs to our kids and our
grandchildren listen to scientists not
to the fossil fuel industry but the
moment isn't what the Democratic Party
has got to do which it hasn't done well
is open the doors we want your ideas we
want your energy if you're a working
person we want to hear what's going on
in your life how do we change our
government so that it represents all of
the people not just the 1% if you're a
young person who can't pay your student
debt what ideas do you have as to how we
make college affordable in other words
we need to bring people into the
political process democracy is not a
spectator sport
people fought and died for ordinary
people to determine the future of our
country and the Democratic Party has got
to enable that to happen
[Applause]
you